marc bueno interrumpía más o menos
nuestra sección de salud pero ya estamos
aquí hablemos del dinero de la
organización mundial de la salud con qué
presupuesto cuenta esta organización
importante saber de dónde recibe este
dinero y cuánto es una organización que
lleva dos años pues marcando mucho de
nuestra vida a raíz de la pandemia de
kobe 19 no el presupuesto de la o ms
ronda aproximadamente los 5 mil 800
dólares durante dos años 2020 2021
parece mucho dinero pero pero en
realidad cuando lo comparamos es
bastante pocos por ejemplo no llega ni
al 0,2 por ciento de todo lo que se ha
gastado eeuu sólo en luchar contra la
pandemia veamos quiénes son los que
aportan más a lo ms no de dónde viene
este flujo de dinero como vemos alemania
es el país que más dinero aporta hay una
parte que son contribuciones
obligatorias y hay otra parte que son
las contribuciones voluntarias muy
importante destacar que en segundo lugar
está una entidad privada la fundación
bill y melinda gates y eeuu que solía
ser el primero está en tercer lugar bajo
cuando trump estuvo en la presidencia y
tuvieron un choque diplomático con la
ms veamos entonces los siguientes
también los siguientes cinco grandes
donantes de la ms reino unido y japón-
también son otros de los principales
contribuyentes también mayoritariamente
a través de sus donaciones voluntarias
la ong de rotary international y luego
otras agencias de la onu que
especialmente a raíz de la pandemia pues
decidieron apoyar el trabajo de la oms
en su lucha contra esta crisis sanitaria
el dinero muchísimas veces es igual a la
influencia y por eso marx le quiero
pedir en toén le quiero preguntar qué
tanta influencia pueden llegar a tener
estos países a través de sus donaciones
pues lo vimos por ejemplo con eeuu no
esta influencia puede ser mucha en el
caso de los países que tienen este
músculo financiero y que pueden dar
tanto dinero a la ms fue cuando trump
dijo que no quería participar más de la
ms pues fue un duro golpe para su
presupuesto entonces se podría decir que
hay una cierta dependencia hacia estos
grandes donantes que suponen un
porcentaje alto del presupuesto total de
la organización mundial de la salud pero
hay otra manera en que los países pueden
influir y es a través de estas
donaciones voluntarias no las donaciones
obligatorias son como un cheque en
blanco para la o ms mientras que las
donaciones
y pueden ir destinadas a programas
específicos que decidan los países y
esto era precisamente lo que nos
destacaba francisco becerra ex
subdirector de la psa a quien
entrevistamos previamente
obviamente de violas las visiones
nacionalistas pueden jugar un papel muy
importante
pero
pueden decir cómo me interesa apoyarte
pero te voy a dar los dineros de manera
etiquetada para los problemas que yo
considero de nivel global que son
importantes todo va por resolución todo
va por programa y todos los países votan
de igual manera entonces para que haya
una presión específica porque te voy a
dar dinero no va a pasar a menos de que
dell etiquetó un hotel etiqueta
lo estaba también destacando ahí este
etiquetado que influye pero igualmente
es importante recordar que todas estas
decisiones se toman en conjunto por
votación con todos los países en la
asamblea nacional de la salud entonces
hay una influencia pero no deja de ser
limitar entonces finalmente de cuánto
dinero dispone la ome s para decir cómo
gastarlo pues la verdad es que es poco
porque con todas estas donaciones que
son tan voluntarias tanto de los países
como de las entidades privadas el dinero
que realmente le queda a merced no a
disposición de la organización mundial
de la salud no es tanto es
aproximadamente sólo el 20 por ciento
del presupuesto total al menos de esa
cifra fue la del 2018 2020 2019 2020
2021 se redujo hasta el 12 por ciento
del presupuesto total y es por eso que
la actual dirección de la ms pues está
intentando cambiar eso y hacer que las
contribuciones obligatorias de los
países lleguen a ser el 50 por ciento de
su presupuesto una decisión a la que se
oponen bastantes gobiernos entre ellos
el de eeuu mar hablabas de las entidades
privadas le pregunto entonces el papel
que ellas juegan dentro de la mesa pues
dentro de la umh s por suerte no está
aunque también orientan un poco estos
presupuestos como decíamos no vemos que
por ejemplo es la fundación bill y
melinda gates destina una gran importa
una gran parte del presupuesto de la oms
y preocupa pues pueden surgir preguntas
alrededor de qué influencia puede tener
una entidad privada por ejemplo vemos
que la gran mayoría del dinero que da la
fundación es para un programa específico
el 60 por ciento de sus aportes van al
programa de la ms para erradicar la
polio eso no deja de ser un objetivo
pues muy encomiable y que además forma
parte de los objetivos de la
organización mundial de la salud pero al
menos a nosotros cuando estábamos
revisando esta información nos levantó
una serie de preguntas de interrogantes
y por eso pues le trasladamos esta
pregunta al doctor francisco becerra yo
creo que aquí se unen los dos intereses
la erradicación de la polio y el que
haya una fundación dispuesta a dar
dinero suficiente para subsanar a una
gran cantidad del presupuesto que se
requiere para la erradicación de la
enfermedad que sería muy diferente en el
que hubiese alguna la asociación que
recibiera por fuera dinero de alguna
industria y empujará un tema muy
específico que no está dentro del plan
estratégico dentro de la misma agenda de
la reversión mundial de la salud es
decir que en cierta medida hasta que
mientras los objetivos sean compartidos
pues no hay tanto de que preocuparnos
también porque la ms tiene unos filtros
por ejemplo no hay entidades como que
trabajen con alcohol tabaco armas que
puedan donar dinero a los meses entonces
pues también ya hay unas condiciones
unos filtros unos marcos de trabajo para
intentar que no vayan a más estas
influencias más muchísimas gracias
entonces por toda la información de
salud nos vemos la semana que viene con
más feliz fin de semana nosotros pasamos
a hablar con nuestro segundo invitado
del día